nothing brings the ditch to life better
than fresh herbs am I right oh yeah but
sometimes it can be annoying to like
here's parsley like he loves me he loves
me not right it's annoying well you just
made it really cute but look I'm gonna
show you how to de-stem your herbs
really quickly here's like a cheese
grater we all have this in the kitchen
all right all right so I'm gonna take a
piece of parsley I'm gonna stick it
right there see that little hole and
then I'm gonna grab the stem and
boom look
the leaves came right off that worked a
lot better than I thought it was going
to yeah you want to try it I do I'm like
okay get a real a real bushy one and
then
okay I'm gonna go well am I in here all
right so and then grab grab this part
okay the handle and one two three we're
gonna pull together hold on I haven't
okay ready yeah one two three
what's wrong with me